Hello everybody Oh my god it's so weird Oh our very first
stream With our new skin suit guys Oh it feels It feels a
little bit weird to be honest Oh I was like trying to figure
out like How big should I be on the screen Like I don't know
I don't know I was trying to like figure it out Alright so
um We have like a lot of updates and stuff I know the intro
The intro is still not updated yet It's actually done But um
I am trying to figure out what color background to use So
it's either gonna be a different background or it's gonna be
the same But it is done and I basically hibernated for 24
hours after the debut.
I was just I was gone I can't after the after the like uh
re-debut I I was out I was actually like brain dead like I I
couldn't I was so tired I like woke up from my sleep and I
was so mentally just drained because all the stress and like
all the preparations that kept inside it was like it's over
and then like it all cop up to me and i'm like this would be
how i felt if i didn't hold it in i was just i was like
talking to my staff team today i was talking to my like we
had a meeting and then i was like i'm so tired
They were like, all right, we gotta do this, we gotta do
that, and they're like, are you okay, Doki?
I'm like, I'm so tired.
So I was just like, okay, I'm, I can't, I need a, I need, I
need a rest.
I'm, I know everybody's watching me because the debut was so
successful, but I need a sleep.
now I'm tired but I I really really really wanted to try out
the early access the early access for the newest big update
for pal world was it called the Sakura Jima the Sakura Jima
update because Hiro messaged me and was like hey I I have
early access.
I have early access.
Do you want to check it out?
Do you want to stream it?
And I was like, oh my God.
You know, because she has early access for two days.
So I was just like, okay, Joki, I know today you promise
behind the scenes.
But then, but early access is the only time to be like, I
have early access and you don't know, Joki.
I want to be like, all right, I want to show you guys.
the early access for the new pal because I know I know some
of you guys would be like pal world oh my god we watched so
much power but no this is different this is new content this
is new content pal world so there's things you've never seen
before this time so it's and I never got to stream power for
you guys I never yeah you might have watched a hundred
thousand other people play pal world but you never watch
dokey play pal world
and I compared to the other people that played Powell they
don't have early access like me so you have to watch this
stream um but yes uh I uh oh yeah sorry I forgot about
Twitch your eyes yeah but you know some YouTubers YouTube
people don't watch Twitch and they don't know the existence
about my Twitch VOD channel.
So Madrid, a lot of people, a lot of Dragos did not watch me
play Pow World.
And this is Pow World on my YouTube channel that you weren't
able to.
Yeah, it's a tournament chat.
It was different.
Stakes were high.
Tensions were high.
People were yelling at each other.
Now instead, I'm just gonna yell at you instead.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, but It was a clip compilation.
That is different.
A clip compilation is not a real thing because there's no
social interaction by being live on chat.
I'm sorry for the VOD watchers, but we can pretend I'm live
for you if you're VOD watching right now.
We can pretend that we're live together if you're VOD
watching right now.
Anyway, as I was saying, so i really wanted to stream the
early access because in two days i won't it wouldn't be
early access uh so that's why i was like okay i gotta stream
early access before everybody has access to it
um and then that uh i'm definitely gonna take it much more
uh chill i know like i still have like three streams for the
week uh with this one and then chain together with rpr and
ditto um which might be a very terrible idea because i don't
know how bad the ping's gonna be what server we're gonna be
playing chain together and we have to be in sync while
everybody has well one of us is gonna have 200 ping so i i
don't i i i don't know how it's gonna go when you know one
of us is gonna go in with 200 to 300 ping playing a game
that requires synchronization of jumps so we're doing it be
like three two one jump one of us has to jump at two
so this might been a very terrible idea um when it's already
a rage baiting game and then we have the behind the scenes i
know i said i was gonna put it earlier but like i said like
a lot of things moved around and it lets the team have a
chance to uh put together like all the things they want to
me to talk about uh during the behind the scenes but yes
shout out to the project team um we had like a little
celebration right after um it was a great pleasure working
with everybody there and we are actually gonna upload a
director's cut of um of the whole like the the debut video
we're gonna have a director's cut because there was some cut
content a little bit of cut content in there and we want to
like uh brush it up a lot more so you get like deleted
content and also the uh like adjusting the sound balancing
adding more sound effects and everything fixing it all up a
director's cut will be uh will be uploaded in the future um
anyway blade thank you for the magenta soup ah thank you
thank you clip clip out of context thank you for the magenta
soup ah thank you thank you oh my god i'm so bouncy now you
guys can actually see me actually like i actually move
around a lot when i talk but you guys never really see that
now you're oh i'm so self-conscious because now you actually
see me I'm like a very I like to if you guys see like my
hand tracking too I actually talk with my hands as well.
So like I'm so bouncy.
Oh my gosh.
It's weird.
I'm never I'm never like I'm not used to like having you
guys see how how bouncy I actually am when I'm when I'm
talking sure okay i have to tell you guys a funny story so
like i i thought that um for pal world when they said new
world also limo thank you for the 50 gifted ships thank you
thank you i really appreciate it thank you so much um but
when they said uh it's like new world i legitimately thought
like we were gonna be transported into like a entire new map
but no it adds on to the map and then so um so very funny
story i was very confused because i was like oh hiro um
where is this place and they were like oh just run northwest
and you'll get there so i was like oh okay so the thing is i
start i'm I'm starting a whole new world because I never I
um um I I didn't have a world yet so uh the thing is uh I
started a whole new world and uh um I I got in I was like I
wanted to see if I could find it before I start the stream
so at least like we can we hadn't cut the time of me finding
it on stream so I was like I had level one trying to fucking
run to find this new area and then I had to swim because she
was like northwest little do I know it was not just
northwest and I will give you like an illustrated like I was
like you know can you like circle it on the map what do you
mean northwest and She sent me the map.
I was like, I was never gonna make it by just running.
I looked at it, I was like, hey, I was never, what do you
mean?
Just run Northwest.
What do you, what do you, okay, I'll, I know how to get
there, though.
I know, I know how to get there.
Let me, all right, we're gonna name a new world.
dragon islands we'll do a dragon islands and then we have to
turn multiplayer on and we'll do uh well okay i think that's
fine i don't really care about like uh i mean we can make
the night time faster you know what
we'll make it 15 all right and then uh there is a reason
There is a... There is a reason... No, no, guys.
Okay, when you see it, there is a reason.
Okay, we don't need that much long nighttime.
Like, what are we gonna do at night?
There's a reason.
No, you have... No, there's a reason.
I'll show you guys.
I'll show you guys why.
Why?
Okay, give me a... Um...
reason um you know 15 to 20 you're right let's just get a
good middle ground guys let me give you guys i have a reason
why i did this there's no i i swear to god i swear to god
there's a reason why guys i swear and i'll show you why when
i'm in um there I I figured out why alright uh let's do a
classic okay uh and then what was it it was like oh yeah
there we go there we go bringing back bringing back uh
twitch rivals dokey uh I think I was like this face, right?
Or was it?
Oh no, it was this one.
It was this one.
And then it was...
Which pupil was it?
It was... I think it was a normal pupil.
We have more of a teal color.
Maybe like...
What is this?
Is that my eye color now?
Don't remember.
It was like this.
Yeah, there you go.
That's my eye color now.
And then blonde...
Oh God, I'm so bad with colors.
There we go.
go so you know it's all natural i didn't dye my hair
so you know it's all natural there was no hair color dye oh
this is harder because like there's no actual like my
hairstyle this time around so it is a little more difficult
because i'm like which ones which one is this my hairstyle i
guess i guess or is it this Is this my hairstyle?
I guess, right?
I feel like this is much more of my hairstyle.
Oh, I wish I could just copy the color that I put in there.
Okay, there you go.
And it has just, like, less like that.
Yeah, I think that's good.
I think...
I think that's good.
Alright.
Yeah, let's just go with average.
Okay, there we go.
real female doki i forgot oh i think i was just doki beard i
think all right uh maybe i should do real female doki there
you go so you guys will know you know it's me all right i'll
show you guys why uh eating all those crabby patties okay we
all don't need to see the intro we've seen this intro like
10 million different times okay so guys i okay so guys this
is where we're at right so this is where we're at okay so
and then my friend
she she linked me the map and it's all the way on the top
left it's all the
Do you want to know where we are?
I'll show you where we are on the map, guys.
For those who are like, but where are we, Doki?
Where are we, you say?
We are here.
That's where we are.
So I was like...
And then the hero was like, run northwest.
That was my instructions.
So I was like, okay.
And then I was like, I can't find it, you know.
I can't find it.
And the hero's like, oh, don't worry.
I got the map.
It's here.
I just thought it was so fun.
And the hero's like, oh yeah, by the way, you have to die
and respawn.
You have to respawn.
But I didn't know.
I should have asked for more instructions.
Oh my god.
I didn't know.
So the plan is that we have to die.
And then after we die, we go to top level.
um we go here this is where we are guys we have the respawn
here
um and then and then after you respawn you see that that
that's the place over there
is over there that's our new place that we have to go it's
all the way over there okay up the volume a little bit too i
uh no sorry whoops sorry i almost doxed you sound guy the
openness secret all right it could be anybody it could be
anybody guys it could be anybody chat um oh it's so clear I
don't think they know this guys uh sound guy I don't I don't
think they know this sound guy it could be anybody anybody's
name starts with a you know um all right all right here we
go it's guys I need to heal up a little bit before I start
swimming I know I have these muscular legs but like it's
still pretty I died one trying to swim all the way there.
All right.
I need to like reheal, like, self-heal a little bit.
All right, here we go.
All right.
Okay, I realize that my endurance is...
Okay.
I almost forgot.
All right.
We have to go up here.
We have to go all the way up here and then jump over here
and then swim.
And then, then we swim.
yeah his name is audio guy chat all right there you go then
that's how you go to sakura jima mushroom area um that's how
you get there see there's a reason why i have to wait until
i like had like regen my hp because i already lost my
stamina and there you go i got a mushroom and i leveled up
yay all right let me push up the auto a little bit more i
think there's like a i push up the audio too all right nice
okay so i'm pretty sure you can edit the sound i haven't
right yeah is there anything we need to edit uh audio whoops
wait what did i press why my eyes sparkling what
Okay, I need to make sure.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Okay, we definitely don't need.
Okay, guys, I cannot look at my settings.
I did not.
Okay, no camera shake.
I don't know if you guys noticed, but I did not look at my
settings at all.
All right, here we go.
And then game settings, toggle, sprint on.
Okay, let's get the sensitivity a little bit low.
And we should be good.
All right, bring down.
the ambient sound down a little bit all right uh ambient
i'll put it at 70 and i'll bring this up all right let me
know if it's better all right okay let me fix my thing how
do i oh my gosh how do i um oh that's my clip guys i don't
remember anything
Oh no.
Give me a sec.
I don't remember anything.
Those are my glasses.
I don't need to wear my glasses.
Okay.
I set it all up on a little device.
Guys, I'm still learning, guys.
I'm not used to having so many things.
It's weird.
It's so weird.
All right.
There we go.
Now I have my eyes again.
All right.
all right and now we're here look and this is the reason why
i had to level up real i need to level up really fast
they're level 45 this is a this area this this area is it's
a they're very high level so what happened was that i was
minding my own business exploring the area because i was
like oh okay i should like figure this out you know i was
like oh i should like i should know what's going on before
like know how to get here you know like find the first find
the first area that has like the checkpoint that has no
we're friends right Yeah, they're a little pussy.
They're little bitches, too.
So you don't have to worry about these guys.
They're very afraid of you.
But I bumped into a clan of enemies that were not afraid of
me.
And I was like, oh, they're pretty cute.
Look at those frogs.
And then I looked at these frogs.
And they turned around and beat my ass.
It literally took one hit and I was gone.
So, for those who are going to go to Sakura Jima, do not get
near the frogs.
Do not get near.
Do not get near the frogs.
The frogs will kill you.
So, be careful of the frogs.
They will absolutely kill you.
literally one hit me i was gone i got i got jumped on by the
frog mafia um i was like oh cute there's those fries and
then um and then there i go um i was gone i wish i still had
my old world
if i knew i would have brought my old world uh i would have
brought my old world into the beta so at least i think i was
like level 30 in my old world um so yeah we're starting back
at zero and that is why that is that no i can't it's gone
forever that that is why we had to set up the XP leveling up
thing.
Oh, okay.
Look at him.
Look, he's such a...
Oh!
I thought...
Okay, I didn't think he'd actually chase me.
No, please.
Someone, my chat said to hit you, and I thought it would be
funny!
Okay.
We're fine.
We're okay.
Yeah, do not hit a level 46 dinosaur despite what your inner
thoughts are telling you.
intrusive thoughts say do not do not try to beat up a level
level 46 I'm trying to find the first checkpoint it's like
somewhere here I found it before it was like here okay
there's a lot there's a lot going on oh but I found an
effigy though let's go ah alright all right here we go where
where do we go oh there it is there it is there is the first
the first checkpoint the first checkpoint uh all right it's
fine see nothing to worry about there's apparently a lot of
new pals as well and there's like there's like treasure
there's like an oil rig um and you can actually get oil now
and there's like oil strongholds and everything um and then
there's like the these are the frogs over there whatever
they're not called the crojero be careful the crojero they
are not friendly if you're like even like five centimeters
see look look oh shit
no it's so far
that's what i mean if you just look at Please, I just, I
just wanted to, I just wanted to look.
Oh my god.
I told you guys, you can't even look at them.
They just, they don't care.
I just wanted to be friendly.
Look, I leveled up though.
I'm level four now.
I'm just a baby I didn't realize okay that was a little bit
of my fault because I didn't realize I didn't realize the
range of that fucking attack I'm gonna get my shit back
though I need to get to the checkpoint over there before
anything happens I need to I need to get to the checkpoint I
need at least claim the checkpoint that's all I want please
I just I just want only 41 more levels to go I just I just
wanted to claim the checkpoint that's really it I just
wanted to claim it oh my god okay don't worry it's gonna be
fine it's gonna be fine I just wanted to explore oh no it's
getting dark I don't know what type of pals show up in the
dark but there's a new type of um a new type of currency uh
where look at them run that's right run that's fucking right
get out of here get out of here that's right yeah yeah
you're afraid of me oh no he's fucking i train very hard to
get these legs no there's a new form of pal that's oh my god
oh my god i tied so far there's a oh my god fuck this though
let me put these up okay all right uh there's a new form of
pals that holds currency that you had to capture or kill i'm
not sure but i was reading up on like the the new stuff so
like to see if i can get there um and basically it's like
it's so weird it's like it's called dog coin i think they
were trying to make a parody of dogecoin and it oh rest in
peace by the way i don't know if you guys know this but like
the the doge finally passed away after 20 plus years and i'm
oh my god like it i was like i was just like oh rest in
peace because because like he was she was like blind death
and had to wear diapers and i was just like oh my god like i
was just like oh my god she can finally be at peace oh my
god like anyway um she was really really old also i am i
don't know where to go uh oh no okay uh anyway uh i was
surprised i didn't realize no i can't can't see i yeah she
was very well loved she was kept i was so surprised finding
out guys i fucked up i i don't know where i i i don't know
no oh no i so this is bad okay do i have a torch do i have a
where am i where am i it's just the swamp it's only the
swamp i need a go-to oh it's over here i see the blue light
i see my items anyway uh they they did like dog coin in this
game and um and and like a parent it's like a form of
currency where you can buy pal skins uh and i don't remember
i don't really remember much about it it was like you can
buy pal skins and uh oh okay i need like a i need it like oh
no Oh no, I hear the frog.
Oh no, I hear the frog.
He's angry.
The frog's angry.
Please leave me alone.
I just, I just wanted to get my items back.
Leave me alone.
Yeah, but there's no poison though, so that's good.
Oh, thank God.
He's sleeping.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, I don't want to look back to see.
I'm level one.
I'm level five.
Well, I don't know why I paused there.
I should not be turning away.
around just to see what they are.
Dude, fuck those frogs, though.
I hate these frogs.
All my homies hate so frogs.
Alright, and is that my items?
Is that it?
Oh, thank God.
At least you don't get poison.
I'm so happy.
Thank fucking God there's no...
Oh!
Are they friendly?
Hello?
I don't...
Oh, no.
Oh, okay.
He's running.
Oh, no.
Guys, they were not friendly.
They were...
No!
I died!
My brother is cold.
I'm cold.
I'm starving and I'm dying.
I Just wanted to say hi I don't understand I just
The green ones were friendly
The green ones were friendly.
Why was this one not friendly?
I'm gonna take my anger out on you That's fucking right.
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna take my anger off of you.
I get bullied so you get bullied.
It's a fucking cycle.
Where are you trying to go?
That's right.
I'm not breaking the cycle.
Alright.
Nice.
I'm still cold, so I'm gonna get Mouch off this guy's fire.
to be less cold uh break the cycle that's too late i'm not
breaking any cycles today
the cycle continues um all right we gotta okay we definitely
gotta get that and then we gotta get palisphere uh repair
bench this uh we we need up bed we need this do we need a
repair kit no we don't need cloth we don't need we need
shield feed box hang no we don't need that berries yeah we
don't need any of those i guess we need none of that yeah
violence bring violence all right check the survival guide
all right i did it okay we got I don't want to live here
that's the thing I don't want to live here I just want to
get my items that's all I want I just I don't I don't want
to I just want to get to the checkpoint it's literally right
there the checkpoint is like like next to the my body my
dead body I swear I've seen it.
Gino, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're right, Doki.
This is a unique power stream.
Well worth watching.
Do I even have enough for a torch?
Oh my god.
Oh, Tab.
That's why.
I know I'm doing sparkles.
It's because Tab is my sparkle.
now i know every time i it's like every time i'll be like
it's time to upgrade oh my god it's upgrade time
guys why is it still so dark and cold i don't understand
It's so dark and cold sir.
I said I wanted shorter night time How is night time so
long?
Did I fuck up?
Did I accidentally make night twice?
I thought shorter means shorter night time Oh my god.
I said it back.
Okay guys.
I made a mistake guys uh okay guys i made a mistake we gotta
fix this i didn't realize i actually made it longer i
thought i had made it shorter i was so confused all right
there we go that's better oh so this is the opposite oh okay
things make a lot more sense now so does this mean all right
now i think we can be at like 18 a solid 18 now um and then
that's it all right we figured it out um it's yeah sorry i'm
a little special new skin suit same old dokey so that's when
you know like things are things never change
all right how fast is this then it's gonna be daytime soon
sir do you think the sun's gonna wait it's getting brighter
I can see wait I can see now guys I can see now does that
mean I can make it I think I can make it guys I think I can
make it okay let me figure out how to get there okay I need
to figure out how to get above oh I can see now I can see it
is getting brighter okay all right this is it guys this is
our mission our mission our mission it's we gotta get Get a
checkpoint head back to the old the place we there our new
home over there get to at least level 15 and Then maybe I
don't get one shot like that's our goal
Maybe maybe by then by then things will be okay things will
be okay third times the charm guys Third times the charm we
can make it I believe days or nights are shorter now our
goal kill a frog
that's that's our goal wait no chat on screen oh no okay
i'll fix that later first off we need to figure out how to
guys first off we have to figure out a lot of things first
okay one at a time guys one we have to do things one at a
time there's there's a lot of stuff going on all right one
edge look i gotta compensate okay if i
if i if i if i don't have the front at least i have the back
okay all my assets are all my assets are up in the that's
where all the assets are
All right.
Oh, I see it.
I see the two bright blue lights.
It's right there.
I see it.
Oh, we're gonna make it.
All right.
Oh, I want the effigy, though.
Yay.
All right, we got the effigy right here.
And then we gotta get out of there.
And then...
Oh, my God.
I haven't played Power World in so long.
I remember just... I don't remember what level.
I think I stopped that level three.
Like just playing it, like not in a tournament setting.
Oh my gosh, guys.
I swear, guys, it'll be so cool.
The moment we can make it, the moment we make it here, I
swear.
This place would be so cool.
When I don't insta-dye, you guys are going to see how cool
this place is.
I swear, guys, I'm not coping.
Oh, oh, no.
Oh, no.
I'm sorry.
Don't look at me.
Oh, no.
Oh, okay.
We're fine.
He didn't see me, guys.
He doesn't.
He's afraid of the water.
It's okay.
When the town world become a horror game, guys.
That's the lonely level five trying to figure out their
place in this world.
All right.
We're okay.
We'll head.
We'll head over here.
That's our stuff.
That's our stuff over there.
That's where I died, chat.
Oh, no.
No, it's streamers.
Streamers don't hurt you.
Streamers are the ones that are afraid of you, so we're
fine, chat.
These guys don't hurt you.
See, look.
They're running away.
Look at that.
They don't know.
They're level 46, but they don't know.
They think I'm just as big of a threat as the others.
Wait, there's a key?
When did I get a key when the fuck did i get it what the
fuck did i get a key all right it's just funny little guys
they don't they don't know what to expect they think i'm a
threat i mean i mean if i saw those thighs i'd run away too
is that a free pal ball um vason thank you for the akasupa
thank you thank you dragoons i'm trying to sneak around but
i'm thick and the clap from my ass cheeks keeps alerting the
frogs oh oh what are you oh god it's the frogs it's the
frogs oh god it's oh no i was too dummy thick oh no i can't
believe it okay on cue i alerted them oh that's so cute wait
isn't that different skin that's not the usual one yeah he's
green now because it used to be like full white yeah there's
like the white version up ahead too all right we gotta get
this though yeah see dog coin see i told you dog coin is
real dog coin's real i told you they're real all right so
there's the green version of these guys see look at him
you're so cute is he friendly yeah he's friendly okay thank
god i forgot they're friendly or not so we have like these
guys and then and then like these things over here that's
the oil area i believe so like uh what if i just live here
like this place seems peaceful and there's like rocks
everywhere too And then there's Lulu, which is like, uh,
like, see, they're not afraid of me, and there's an oil rig
here.
Like, what if I just live here?
Like, this is a place where you drill for oil, and there's,
like, rocks here that I can use for mining.
And then there's some trees.
Like, yeah, like, everybody around me is, like, super
fucking strong, but, like, I'll have oil.
Is that all that we want it?
though and like oil's nice i like oil oh yeah this is it see
oh oh nice i got gold coin when did i get a gold coin i
don't even remember that all right so this is a new place um
i am really too weak for this new place there's some new
pals over there the the copyright free cithers over
I'm sorry The legally distinct Purple Scyther Oh shit What
did the sound guys say Um Okay so I did not remember Wait
how many times It's Four times Oops okay Give me a Uh 80 out
of 5.
Let's see.
And then here you go.
Alright.
Let me know.
There you go.
There is.
There is that.
And then... Oh, wait.
Who are these guys?
Are these guys the rebels?
Who are they?
I've never seen them before.
Where are these guys?
The moonflower
who are you guys i know you're not friendly
okay okay now okay there's samurai guys i need to stop
looking oh my god they're so fast but they can't climb
they're so stupid they can't oh my god they're so fucking
holy shit what the fuck what is so fast oh my god oh they're
so fast oh they're so fast i didn't realize how fast they
are oh my god it's time to run holy shit why are they so
fucking fast there's nowhere to go they can't get up here
like nerds you guys can't get up here i have the high ground
now that's right.
Alright, they're level 55 3.
I'm not gonna fuck with these guys.
I'm not gonna...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Um... Oh, there they are!
No, there's a pink chilence.
There's a... The pink chilence.
I assume they're like the fire versions of them.
What the fuck?
They fucking... They ran!
How did you get up here so fast?
Holy shit.
Oh my god, I was just chilling up here Okay, anyway, now
they're pink Now they come in pink now Uh, there's a lot
There's a lot of new things Oh, there's the Sakura Blossoms
Right there, wait, that's new Are these guys friendly?
I'm gonna assume that nobody's friendly here Wait, that
guy's new?
What's that?
Who is that guy?
Look Oh, it's the It's the um Fuck, you know the fox girl?
The other, the other, the fox girl that looks like that
Pokemon fox one?
Now it's, now, now she's red instead of yellow.
Hello, are you friendly?
Oh wait, no, it's a man.
Wait, that's a beard.
Wait, never mind.
Sorry.
Wait, no, you are female.
No, you're female.
You have a beard.
Oh.
Sorry, I saw a beard and just assumed.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, ma'am.
I'm sorry.
It's a goat, yeah.
Wait, this is a nice place to live.
I want to live near the Sakura blossoms.
I feel like this should be my new...
It's Ladybeard, yeah.
This could be my new home.
Look, all these guys are, like, super friendly, too.
A dancing shrine!
They all seem really nice.
I don't feel like they're gonna murder me like the other the
other pals that I bumped into look I know I haven't
established a home yet guys I know but this is important
we've all seen people establish homes like 200 million times
but this is a new area and we're exploring new paths guys
new friends well there's so many of the pink guys there seem
like super common too um yeah we want to check out the
sakura stuff please leave me alone i'm trying to take loot
wait is that that's is that new i don't think that's new i
don't think the yellow birds are new because i'm a yellow
bird i wonder if we can finally head to the tree is that big
tree part of the map now i wonder i actually don't know if
uh the oh it's not nope yeah no that's that's another dlc i
guess that's a i think i'm pretty sure that's a oh there you
go purple ciphers more purple ciphers okay that guy's
freaking out i think is that it is there more to this world
is there more i actually i know like there's nothing more
after the edge of here uh we're not gonna jump guys we are
we guys i have not found another check point yet the closest
checkpoint to us is 200 miles away and all i have are my
legs yes they're thick legs but it doesn't mean i run faster
chat i run as fast as a person who's upgraded stamina once
and even then it's not as fast do a flip all right no wait
sorry no i hear the dungeons there's some new dungeons as
well but i feel like dungeons don't really change much in
general i think my only issue with um well i mean to be fair
this is also like with pokemon and my only issue with like
uh these types of games is that um it gets repetitive uh
really after a while
it gets repetitive after a while after you play for a
certain time i think when you get to like the unless you
have like uh i think even then you have like a server filled
with others it can get repetitive for a bit but this is also
an issue with um pokemon as well uh that's why i stopped
playing pokemon oh my god thank god okay i stopped playing
pokemon after uh paris uh because oh no uh because oh no i
fucked up oh no i'm forever oh no i fucked up guys oh no i'm
stuck in sparkle mode oh no okay there we go yeah the x and
y oh hey look depressed little cat you're depressed here too
why are you depressed oh because we're at the cemetery Okay,
sorry.
Now I know why you're depressed.
I was like, why are you depressed here?
There's Sakura blossom.
Wait, what did I get?
I got leather.
How can you be depressed?
Oh, I'm sorry.
People died here.
That's why.
Are you guys nice people?
Hi.
Yeah?
All right, bye.
All right.
Pokemon peaked with...
I think...
Well, I mean, my favorite Pokemon game was Crystal.
Pokemon Crystal was my favorite Pokemon game.
And also the one where you can have Pokemon follow you
around and everything.
I think that one was my favorite as well.
When the Pokemon follows you around and stuff.
I don't remember which one it was.
But I think Pokemon...
I think Crystal peaked for me.
Alright, explore.
Oh my god.
Wait, this map is a lot bigger than expected.
That's a lot bigger.
Any other issue I have, like, um...
Oh, wait, hey, is that...
That's...
Dark Growleaf.
Is that you?
Are you good?
Yakumo.
Wait, it is!
It's Dark Growleaf!
Oh!
Oh, wait!
no no we thought he got a checkpoint oh wait I did okay okay
did he respond here and I thought he was a good boy how was
I supposed to know that
I thought he was a good boy that sounds like oh good boy
dark girl leave when did they stop being good boys chat oh
my god I should have expected it when he was when he was
dark I should have expected it I knew the darkness overtook
him stop by and say so love see your new smile thank you
thank you i'm glad you've been enjoying my new skin suit
i need to hydrate okay where's where's my body okay i just
you know i'm like those those children that like see any
type of dog and was like oh my god i need to pet him i need
to pet him or her which is not really good because like
children should not like be that open towards petting
strange petting random stranger dogs i can't help it i can't
help it oh my god um i don't know if i've ever told this
story before um but like uh what's it no okay it was like
one of my older older dogs um and uh and like um It was so
scary because, like, we were, I was walking, I was walking
him, and then, oh, wait, stop, get away from my food!
Get away from my backpack!
Oh, wait, no, he's not, okay, never mind.
He's not close to my backpack.
He's not, sorry, sorry, I wasn't trying, sorry, I wasn't
judging you.
I just assumed that, you know, it's not because you're pink,
I'm sorry.
Uh, okay.
Um, and then, like, another dog, like, ran up to my other
dog.
Oh, there he is.
There's dark brown leaf.
Another dog like ran up to my dog and like it was scary
because it looked like he was gonna like, um, he was gonna
like bite him.
It wasn't even a big dog.
It was like the same size.
It was like beagle-esque type deal.
And then instead of like, um, instead of, I don't, I don't
know, because I got scolded because I should not have like,
because like if that dog bit me, and like what if he had
rabies like okay to be fair if he had rabies then he would
not be a pet dog but like i i like instead of like pulling
my dog away i like i like push the other dog away uh you
know i could have like tried to pick up my dog or like you
know uh try to yank like put put myself in between but
instead i just pushed him away he's just like no and then i
and then i got and then he like nipped my hand it wasn't
even like a painful nip i you know apparently you're
supposed to like uh you're supposed to um you're supposed to
get yourself in between but instead i just like pushed him
he just and then he like he like like like not like bite my
head but he was just like all right like my head so there
was like a mark on it but it wasn't like it wasn't like a
cut or anything uh and then and then i got scolded by uh by
the owner and my parents because they're like what are you
fucking stupid
I was like, I don't know.
Like, it was like the first thought in my head.
I didn't want him to fucking bite my dog.
Like, at least I didn't kick him.
Like, why?
I was scared.
I was scared he was going to bite my dog.
So I, like, pushed him away.
Like, I, like, bent down and just pushed him away.
Um, um, um, Uh, Vernon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Doki, love your new look.
I want to recreate your revolver.
Is there any, uh, detail reference for it?
Or where may I find it?
Thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Um, if you look at my Twitter, I actually posted the full
reference sheet.
Um, of what my new skin suit looks like.
All right, guys, after I claim this, um, this checkpoint,
we're gonna actually make a home now.
We're gonna, for real, have like, a place to live.
Whoa.
Wait, that's pretty.
Okay.
We're going to have a place to live for real now.
We're not going to be homeless.
Like, I know I look homeless right now, but I swear to God.
No, we have not had a home in a while, but don't worry.
Now that we figured this game out, figured a new place now,
now we're going to have a home.
We're going to build our home here for now because I don't
know about you guys, but, you know, Everybody else over
there is like super OP and we need like some form of like We
need somewhere to live We actually need some place to live
Also like I didn't mention it before but like one of the
reasons why Like I'd like to keep my new skin suit It is
simpler I want to keep it simple is that I'm here for the
cosplayers out there Other than my hair like and like I
guess other than my hair and gun um it is easier though it's
easy and memorable that was like my goal um yeah thank you
super chat thing thank you uh let's see i'm trying to figure
out where i guess we could live here i mean there's rocks
here there's trees there's rocks i think the only issue is
that the my the uh ores is like so far away that's like the
only issue i have unless there's like a better place uh uh
mc thank you for the super chat thank you thank you thank
you hello is my first chat to you thank you for making me
laugh every day um i'm planning to make a doki plushie yi
meow thank you the super chat thank you thank you i really
appreciate it thank you all right We only have an issue,
and, like, I don't know where the ores are so far away.
That's the only issue, because this is normal rock.
This is just regular rock, and we're going to need ores
soon, so, uh, so, yeah.
Oh, there is ore mines, you're right.
Wait, I don't have to worry about that.
Wait, is there ore mines?
Oh, shit.
Okay, oh, shit, okay.
I was not paying attention.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, okay, okay, attention I was fucking around all right
we're this is a little iffy okay we're gonna um okay we're
we're fine or we can live here there's rock there's one ore
mine and oh there's a bar there's a bar okay all right
everything wants to kill me okay it's fine everything is
fine everything might want to kill me but everything is okay
everything might want okay how about oh i figured it out all
right we're gonna be here so we have oh here is nice because
we have the trees and we have that one rock that one rock is
gonna last us forever uh oh shit okay that was a mistake i
mean i have so many
That was...
Okay, I mean, that works.
New friend.
We have...
Dragoon.
New friend.
I did not mean to catch you, but I guess you're here now.
Anyway, I need to build a primitive new friend.
new new friend um wait what do you do again i forgot what
does the chicken do you are useless okay i mean you're so
special dragon you're you're so don't ever let them call you
useless because you're special to me all right i need a
craft i need a build a what the fuck all right the your
first job you're fine okay let me and then i'll have to
build a i need to build a pal box oh i don't have enough
wood okay you'll be fine you do your thing look i'm looking
at your hp to make sure you're okay okay i should have
should have enough you'll be fine see look at you you're
doing it.
Look!
Oh my god!
Wait, you killed him?
Oh my!
I knew it, Dragoon.
I knew you were never useless.
I knew you were just as good as all the... Don't let those
other dragoons pick on you.
Don't let all those other B-Tuber mascots pick on you,
Dragoon.
I knew you were never useless.
You might, wait, pal dressing facility?
Wait, I can dress you up?
Don't let them.
You might, your only job is just to lay eggs.
We know, you know your purpose, guys.
You know your purpose, Dragoons.
Like, you might be only able to lay eggs and you're not able
to do mine anything or contribute to the base, but you can
lay eggs.
And you beat up a boar.
And that's all that matters to me.
You guys got this.
Wait, we don't have, like, the fragments, though.
That's a little bit of an issue.
I need to find.
I need to find, like, a thing to mine the fragments.
Wait, are you female?
Are you?
No.
Wait, you lay eggs, but you're...
You're special.
You're my special dragon.
All right.
What do I need?
Crap cloth to equip.
Oh, I need cloth.
You're right.
Cloth time.
All right.
Yay.
Wait, there's another dragon over there?
Yeah, but he's not as good as that dragon.
Go over there and beat him up.
up no you're not supposed to be friends with him hit him oh
my god dragon it's survival the fittest now hit him that's
right all right let's see what do the lambs lambs work right
i don't remember might as well all right i gotta get over
here i need you in my army We're friends.
No, there's no friends in pal world Only pal Only workers
No friends only workers In pal world Alright, let's see Oh,
sorry The only issue right now is the fact that It's it to
the numbers okay now you can work all right what do you do
again you are your worker okay go work go be a good pal and
work for me all right all right bring okay i'll bring it up
uh i'm not your pal buddy burrito thank you for the akasupa
thank you thank you all right bring it up to 75 all right
yes all right let's see what do we need pals while bed will
get stressed well i guess it's time guys this is not a bad
company okay i need you guys to know that this this
look you guys willingly worked here
all right let's see i need a crab cloth and equip it and
prepare for a chill night okay how much is a cloth i need
two all right get over here get over here that's fucking
right finish that i'm a supervisor
okay let's see uh what do i need i need to okay we need to
up these these two the most, I feel like.
And then we'll put a little bit.
Um...
Oh...
Craft the cloth.
Oh, yeah, we need the... We need to be able to craft cloth.
Get over here!
That's right.
That's fucking right.
I supervise.
You work.
And then you pay me.
that's fucking right work lambbell work don't make me grab
my dragon over here for the muscle all right oh yeah what do
we call you look he's happy working you work till you die
yay I have clothes now do we get day up you think you have
rights.
Let's see, we need wood, stone, and fiber.
How do we make fiber again?
I don't remember.
Oh, wait, it's like we gotta chop the trees into the wait,
what am I doing?
I can, like, make an axe.
God, it's been so long.
Okay, I need rocks.
Alright.
The sheep will be, oh, you're right.
Let me rename you, sheep.
It's naming time.
It's your naming It's naming time, little guy.
You get to be named.
Chunky.
Goon.
Oh my god, you get to be named.
Congratulations.
Isn't that great?
You get to be named.
All right.
let's see i need a uh i need to grab some more rocks all
right come over here come over here dragons we need rocks
now all right nice grab the some berries and we got beat up
some fucking rocks because we are can i beat up rocks i'm
pretty sure right we don't need the axe slow and steady
It's been a while since I played Palworld.
Welcome, Chonkun, to the mines.
Alright.
Nice.
See, you're lucky, Dragoon.
You're a very lucky Dragoon because you were here first.
So you get treated the best.
You get special treatment.
But don't tell the others.
They'll just know from the way I treat you versus the...
the others the first goon you're like my enforcer you're
like my enforcer dragon so like if all the other goons the
other goons are out of line you're here to enforce them any
means necessary all right let's see if we catch enough lamb
bells or if we catch enough chonky goons it's okay if one
gets sick we'll just replace it with the other
am i i'm not a bad person right okay let's see we have the
rocks now so we need to be able to get this all right where
are you where are you lumbar what that's fucking right that
there we go look You can't say You can't say that Because
Chonky-goon is happy working He's so happy Look at him every
time Every time we make something he smiles What does that
say?
Huh?
Chat?
He always, he's happy whenever he makes stuff for me Wait
there Look at my enforcer Watching me making sure everything
is okay Alright, let's grab this Okay else we need like find
like paladin fragments like that's like one of the only
things we're sort of missing it's just we need to grab like
a find a place for the fragments and stuff uh let's see we
don't really need porches i feel like uh we don't need that
we definitely need a stone pit in the logging pit uh oh it's
gonna bat yeah i want the bat we need a Crusher.
We need hot springs, I guess.
I mean, the forge.
There's a bear trap.
I don't even remember the bear trap.
Oh, okay.
We nairs.
And I think that's fine.
Alright.
Okay.
Let's see.
I think we can... Can we make those now?
We need fragments, stone, and wood.
Okay.
Actually, can I upgrade?
Oh, yeah.
I guess you...
The thing is, you don't need a bed.
Because, Chonky-goon, all I'm saying, you don't need a bed.
Do you know why I know you don't need a bed?
Well, the thing is, Chonky-goon, I made it so the day will
never come.
So the day will never end.
The day's never gonna end.
So you never have to sleep.
so you can get stressed if the night never shows up you
don't need to get stressed if it's never nighttime no night
no break it's only it's we still have plenty of day um i
don't remember how to make fiber though i think that's like
the only I have.
Let's see.
Oh, yeah, I need to put inventory time.
My eyes light up when I get to look at my inventory.
Woo.
Inventory.
Wait, I thought I picked up my axe.
Oh, I didn't.
Okay.
Nice.
All right.
Can I get transported on night shift?
Thank you for the super chat, Kevin.
Thank you.
is that the funny thing is that there's no night shift it's
always day
silly goon thinking that they actually exist silly silly
alright let's grab some wood because I think we need wood we
need wood and like what else do we need I don't remember
actually we'll grab some fucking Ors too.
Real fast.
Other opportunity.
The only way to get promoted.
Is to kill the first dragon.
If you kill the first dragon.
You get to be.
You get promoted.
There's only one promotion in this.
In this world.
Um.
All right, I'll just, I guess I can, I'll make one bed.
Let's say, work for your bed.
That's fucking right.
If you want a bed, you gotta work on it yourself.
One must imagine Chonky going to have you.
Thank you for the super chat, Alan.
Thank you, thank you.
right you want a bed
remember what happened in Pikmin if you try to unionize
I you guys want to know what happens if you unionize don't
worry I'll show you what happens soon
don't worry you'll see you'll see what happens No!
All right, let's grab some rocks real fast.
We still need to find like the, um, the fragments.
Still not the fragments yet.
Uh, Daisy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Kill the goon ahead of you and every goon and you go on one
rank.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, uh, oh, it's neat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's a wonder people volunteer to work with you when you
joke like this.
It is a joke, right?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, let's see.
We gotta find, like, the fragments.
Are there, like, it's harder here because, like, it's
normally not where I would put my first base.
But, like, it's the closest to the new world.
Like, I need to get to the new world.
The new world is right beside me.
I need a head there.
Where the fuck is the fragments?
I don't know where the fragments are.
Alright, thank you.
The Super Chat thing.
Thank you.
Who are you?
Where is Doki?
It's me.
I've always been Doki.
Where the fuck?
What the fuck?
What the fuck is that?
Has that always been there?
Why is there like four fucking eggs?
What kind of spawn is that?
What the...
Has it always been like this?
There's so many what?
There's so many fucking eggs.
There's a family over there.
The council meeting.
Is that...
Oh, I didn't know...
I didn't realize wolves came from...
I didn't realize wolves came from fucking eggs.
Oh my god.
It came from eggs?
Well, I guess like all pals come from eggs in the end.
Alright.
Where are the paladin?
fragments I swear to God literally all I need are the
fragments but I have not found like those like mineable
fragment shit in this area like you would assume this is
like a spawn area so what the fuck they're over here they
live here too oh my god I want a frog what do you do I want
a frog that's fucking right okay all right let's see oh my
god they're baby frogs they exist holy shit the baby frogs
exist all right let's see oh 93 all right let's see here oh
my god they're real they have a baby version of them They're
not level 43.
Oh my god, they're not level 43.
It's over.
It's over for them.
God, I don't... Oh, there's a fragment.
Nice.
We needed a fragment, too.
We really need to find more places for the fragment.
It's still day.
It's never gonna be nighttime.
You're using MegaBuzz exactly.
End.
Yeah, and you're seeing it as if it's a bad thing.
Guys.
I don't remember what my two does.
What does my two does anyway?
I'll never, I'll never know.
Alright.
Oh, there's more.
We need more fragments.
There you go.
Do the normal rocks give fragments?
I thought it was, uh...
Oh, wait, the cats are good workers.
Okay.
over here okay all right dragon look i know your blood
firsty right now i know i know i know your i know your blood
firsty right now do i really get pal fragments from i
thought it was like i thought it was like uh you need like a
special rock for it it's been so long i didn't realize these
also give fragments they give normal fragments yeah i
thought they would give like I thought they give, like,
normal...
Oh, my God.
You can fight them.
I don't care.
Oh, stones dropped them?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
What am I doing?
I should have just been doing this this entire time.
Alright, wait.
Do the frogs do anything?
What is your job?
What do you have?
You...
You gather, you water, and...
Oh, handiwork, transport.
Okay.
nice give me the fragment oh i can find him near water guys
you can tell it's been a while
you can tell it's been a while since i've played this all
right get away get away frogs all right let's go back home
and uh we go back home and see we can find the fragments
over on the edge of the near the water I need to find wait
wait there's a chest here there's a purple do I have purple
key I do I got gold coin alright let's see if there's
anything here oh wait I can upgrade stamina there you go I
do it no alright nice it's nighttime it's nighttime dragon
it's nighttime dragon It's nighttime.
You think you can sleep?
You may be my number one enforcer.
But that means you never sleep.
It's only work time.
You're right.
There's only one.
Your shift is 24 hours.
Seven days a week.
Tascaru, I love to work Yay Oh, I went the wrong way Home is
this way Uh, what's this?
Dark skill fruit Poison Blast I've never seen this before
That's the first time I've seen that Uh, oh no We're Amazon
workers Alright Guys, we're almost home We're almost home,
guys.
How's my good worker?
Is my good worker having a good time?
All right, let's see.
I haven't seen my family in nine weeks.
You don't have a family anymore.
The only family you have is us.
All right.
Oh, nice.
You leveled up, my little guy.
all right let's see where's the where's the where's the
chonky goon where is he where did he go
um all right we got built we actually know what am i doing
we have to build the stone pit first we'll build a stone pit
here all right where is he where are you that's right you
thought you could hide but i know you love to work i know
you love to work two minutes yeah all right let's you do
that and then i'm gonna i need wood all right give me a sec
it's okay although we can't see anything it's okay I don't
know.
You thought I knew you love work, so it's okay.
The moment you thought you could hide, but the moment I put
that shit down, you come back to work like a good dragon.
You know you can't avoid it.
Okay, I'll do this myself because it's three seconds.
I guess I'll try a little.
No, we have enough.
Wait.
Oh, yep.
Can't stop.
You think you can stop?
You still have a long way to go.
Guys.
You think...
Oh, you think you're going...
You think you can just sleep?
No, no, no.
Wait, yes, you can.
Wait.
Never mind.
I guess you can.
I hate it.
never mind okay that that ruins things a little bit
what do you mean you can just leave this is not what i
planned i also put the bed here too wait i can't build here
okay let's just put it here all right sleep while you still
can't oh the night is going the night is going by so fast
the night is going by so fast in like 10 seconds it's okay
you're awake for like you're awake for like um for like 18
hours and you sleep one hour wait sorry 23 hours you're
awake for 23 hours and you get one hour of sleep every day
is that great guys okay i should eat and i guess you get two
berries too, because I feel a little generous.
All right, it's time to wake up.
It's work time.
It builds morale.
Exactly.
You understand?
Let's see.
Do I still have... I still don't have enough for a shield.
I'm gonna find, like, a place to grab fragments.
It's so difficult.
Let's see.
That's literally all I need.
Just like a place for fragments.
Woo!
Okay.
I hope there's stuff here.
Right?
There might be stuff here.
Okay.
That's...
Well, we need you for berries anyway.
So...
Go.
Go, go, dragoons.
Go dragoons.
Go.
I believe in you.
Come on, you're literally level 12.
You're the fucking bush.
Beat you up.
That's fucking right.
Kill the plants.
In game.
I love the environment.
God damn.
Alright, that's fine.
I don't really care.
I know it's a mega spirit, but I can literally...
I can literally swim to the level...
Wait, what?
Oh shit, I thought you were captured.
Alright.
Beat the berries out of her.
Nice.
Okay.
Yes, I'm level 13 now.
Yay.
Let's see if I'm the fragments.
Yes, I know I'm using the Megasphere, but I can literally,
like, I can, like, go to the forbidden lands and, like, pick
up 20 of them.
Like, easy.
You, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Today is my birthday.
Thank you for giving us a good time every time.
Your voice makes me smile.
Love you, Doki.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear you.
Yeah!
Oh, wait.
There's more Palladian fragments.
That's good.
We actually need that.
Oh, Palladian fragments are so difficult to find.
This is a terrible... Why did you guys...
make me spawn no i'm joking i'm joking it's not your fault
sorry it was just instinct like blaming others is just
instinct right now because it's never the streamers fault
it's never the streamers fault guys um okay but we're family
now chat we're a family and family takes responsibility
together guys we're a family right
guys remember we're a family get the pickaxe, gotta get that
bench, we gotta we don't need medicine, if you're sick we'll
just replace you
um alright uh dragoons get night paid for this, when the
night is like 30 seconds, I don't think anybody is getting
paid for 30 seconds of work thank you for this super chat,
thank you, thank you uh nix, thank you for the super chat,
thank you, thank you love your new skin suit, keep being on
being you.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
I appreciate it.
Uh...
What's he doing in the water?
Is he stupid?
What the fuck is he doing trying to swim?
Alright.
Everyone run for his.
All I'm saying is don't make me angry.
Guys, I might I might force i'm gonna i'm gonna swap bases
this base fucking sucks i'm gonna go to my usual base
there's barely any fragments here this is like the worst
area to start i know i whenever i get high level i move back
like this area drop one no what do you mean i'm sorry i
didn't notice i'm just stupid all right guys we're moving
guys we're moving It's time to move.
Okay, how do I How do I Fucking destroy this?
I don't remember Guys, how do you destroy stuff Again?
I don't remember
Uh Oh, it's a C It's okay, it's B, okay, how do I destroy
stuff again?
I'm trying to remember how Oh, do I just hit it?
B and Let's see.
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, I had to assemble.
Yes.
No bets for you guys.
No.
Oh.
Oh, this is bad.
This is very bad.
Nope.
Okay.
I'm going to you're gonna eat your own child first and then
we're gonna fucking throw this away really fast and then
we're going to uh you're going to stay in my pocket and
we're gonna destroy you too goodbye we don't live here
anymore we'll come back for you and now we don't need any of
these All right.
Come on, guys.
We're going back to where the default spawn is.
We'll come back to the new world soon.
I swear to God.
All I want to do is...
You know what?
I'll just have Dragoon be, like, super fucking strong.
And then we're going to swim there.
We're returning home.
Back to where we all stay.
started
All right, it's okay.
It's okay dragon.
We're almost there We're almost there.
All right, I'm fucking I'm going back here.
Oh my god, no Wait
Oh no, I forgot I forgot.
Okay, I have a plan.
I have a plan, guys.
I have a plan.
Okay, guys, we're going to get a little, we're going to get
a little quirky here.
We're going to get a little quirky here.
Okay, I didn't think this through.
Okay, we're going to get a little quirkier, guys.
You're going to, all right, let's put it.
these guys away first uh and then and then we'll put away
the important stuff and then plan b
we have figured this out exactly exactly back to where it
all started all right nice all right guys it's like nothing
look see it's that easy there we go
okay all right and i get free stuff look see i got free
stuff guys all right and then back here
easy and there it is I told you guys, not that difficult.
I'll take all of that away and I'll just leave this chest
here because I'm lazy right now.
Nothing bad happened.
Yeah, see, I'm just taking advantage of the mechanics, chat.
I'm just taking advantage of them.
And then we live here.
This is like, see, this is what I mean.
This is literally all the good shit.
Look at all these fragments.
I was like, where the fuck are the fragments?
This is like the best place to ever...
Why would you spawn anywhere else?
Well, not here.
But like, um, down here.
I usually place my base right there.
Because it literally has everything I need.
It has the ores, the fragments, the...
The sheep I'm gonna beat up and let my anger out.
Um, and see, everything we ever need is right here.
spot to build um i'll build it here all right all right here
we go no matter even if there's a new update this is always
like the place to be all right frog sheep all right guys and
then oh my god i can dress you guys up now wait what is this
all right work work yes work.
Yes.
Good.
My good workers.
That's right.
Only one hour has passed since only one one day hour has
passed.
Change the skin.
Oh!
That's what it does?
Oh my god, where's the cat?
Get over here.
I need you to have glasses.
All right.
Oh my god.
Yeah!
You're cool now.
You're so cool.
All right.
You're not cool.
You're not cool enough.
Oh my god, what does he do?
He mines.
Look at him!
He's cool now!
He's so cool!
All right, what do I need to upgrade?
I need a primitive workbench and a shoddy bed.
Okay, that works.
So now I can have Chonky-goon back in there.
Wait, who should he be?
The cooler-goon?
Oh, you're right.
Okay.
Uh...
The cooler-goon.
can't see my tears behind those shades thank you for the
super chat cast thank you thank you honey thank you the
super chat thank you thank you fun trick you can donate your
base to close console remotely and treat the resource to
rebuild it from anywhere good for moving lots of stuff
easier my gosh why didn't i know this before all right let's
see uh skins obtained inside and outside of the game can be
applied here so i guess you might be able to unlock up to to
have to like i guess like to um to like dress up your paths
that's right that's good you wear the glasses still they
don't know how much you're not getting paid if they can't
see the tears are you actually crying
if you think about it Okay, we need the workbench.
All I'm seeing is pal, pal, sad, and decreased while doing
more, causing them to slack off.
Who's slacking off?
Who is it?
Who's slacking off right now?
Alright, we gotta build a home.
Uh, let's see.
Alright.
And then...
How do I make a roof?
There you go.
There.
That's all we need.
Now build my bed.
What's your name?
You need a new name.
When you work for Doki Production Incorporated, you get a
new name.
Be gone with your old name, Froggoon.
You get a new name when you work for Doki Bird.
Eliminate your past self.
This is new you.
You're right.
It should be one word.
You're right, guys.
Froggoon.
There we go.
Nice.
He builds my bed.
Yeah, and if anyone's slacking off, you gotta pay me.
Oh, okay.
I don't even need a door.
That's great.
I just...
Let's see.
Can I upgrade my base so I can put Chonky Goon back in here?
Chonky Goon is back to work time.
It's work time again.
Donkey-goon.
Hey, um...
What do I need to upgrade this?
I think we're making good progress.
Feed box.
You guys need food?
Wait.
Are you trying to tell me you need food?
You need to be fed?
I don't know.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, I need wood, too.
Okay.
The pal's over 400 a year.
That's hilarious.
Please don't make me laugh so much.
Alright, let's see.
I need to be able to...
Wait, can I create it?
Where's my workbench?
Where is my workbench?
Oh, I see.
Good thing I have my pickaxe.
all right let's see let's grab these ores real fast all
right i gotta create some stuff i need to create some
certain things real quick guys stone and flame organs okay i
clearly don't have enough stone and i need to kill some
foxes too all right guys give me a sec jokey needs to head
off for some business a doki needs to head off on a business
trip real fast guys give me a bit
doki please guys give me a sec doki needs to go on a
business trip with a little bit of murder um johnny thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you we already get
negative uh pay but you slack up you'll get more negatives
faster especially what is it especially hugs unless you're
into that sort of thing i guess yeah i know hugs right
there's no censorship here thank you for the super chat
johnny thank you thank you where are the flame guys where
are they where are the where are the where the fire tails i
know you exist i've seen you guys
No need to hide.
I've seen you roaming around.
I want to give a hug.
Where are you, Lot?
I've seen you guys travel around here.
Alright, let's see.
We might have to go back to the original home to see if we
can find the Flame Boys.
Don't worry.
Flame Boy.
Where are you?
Where are you, Flame Boy?
Narnia, just think of the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your new skin suit really suits you, Doki.
Thank you.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I know it shows how kind I am.
It really does.
Where are the Flame Boys?
I've seen your tails flying around before.
I know you're alive for now.
Hey, flame boys, where are you?
Why do I have an axe you say?
I just wanted to ask you something, you know?
It's just a little joke.
You know what?
I want this guy.
You work for me now.
I'm going to duck your fam.
I'm going to duck you like a kid.
All right.
You will never see your family again.
You're level two, so you're almost a child.
Yay!
You're gonna work on my company.
You're gonna work in my company now.
Yay!
Just wanna ask you a little question.
I adopted him.
He had no family, guys.
That poor little monkey had no family.
Oh my god it was so sad He had no family and I adopted him
Oh my god now he's gonna be okay now Chat
Oh there you are There you are Oh you're gonna run You know
what's gonna happen to you You're gonna run Oh
You think you can run away?
That's really cute.
Oh, he does think you can run away.
Oh, I'm so cute.
Oh, get over here.
I don't even need to catch you.
I just need your fucking organs.
It's organ transplant time.
I'm here to take your kidneys.
Yay.
All right, nice.
We did it.
Run for your life.
Nice.
I got...
Oh, nice.
Okay, I need one more.
All right.
No!
All right, let's see.
Oh, there's more of that frog, guys.
All right, I don't care about these guys, though.
They do not.
We're going to make sure they're extinct.
They get endangered.
Not Oregon trafficking.
What are you guys talking about?
What the fuck is wrong with them?
sleeping what's going on are they okay did i kill them when
i kill these guys who killed them wait i didn't kill them
then who did i didn't kill them at all oh it's the syndicate
how dare they're taking my job oh there's more there they
are all right dragon you can take care of the syndicate.
I need to harvest some organs real fast.
Alright, get over here.
You know what?
I need one of you guys.
I don't need two, though.
I just need one.
That's a king, right?
That's Doki's job.
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
There we go.
I just need one of you.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
I'm just gonna watch this.
You guys won't die, Dragon.
You're literally level 15.
How are you gonna die?
There we go.
Good job.
Now I'm gonna fucking loot them.
Yay!
Look, they have a bounty.
I'm here to collect it.
It says dead or alive and I chose dead.
Alright.
Time to head home, Dragons.
Time to head home.
I needed one of the fire guys so I can make the ores.
Doc, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki is a really kind boss.
I once asked for a raise, and she doubled my pay.
T-Bit was negative before she doubled it.
Yeah, that's unfortunate, man.
Oh, how do I head home?
Why is this way?
All right.
Oh, I can level up, though.
Level up time.
Work speed, weight, stamina.
I feel like that's really it.
I don't really need health.
Not gonna lie.
I feel like.
All right.
I'm so generous.
Look at my tail.
Testimonies, you don't believe me?
Read all the testimonies right now.
They all call me kind.
If I wasn't so kind, if I wasn't such a good boss, where
would I get all these testimonies, chat?
Dark Blade, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
I work at Doki Dragoon Construction Agency, and I love it.
Doki's a great leader and would never hurt us.
She turned my life around.
I speak 100% truth and totally am not under God.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dark Blade, remember when like when you were an orphan and I
took you in you know I found you and took you in dark blade
and I gave you a job and a pay and everything I gave you a
bed to sleep Dark Blade remember that
Hey, where the fuck is the where the fuck is the the
teleporter?
Alright, let's see.
It's not kidnapping!
He needed a home.
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Capture Rebel and name him Sound Guy.
We need a manager.
Alright, let's see.
It's over here.
There's a teleporter.
They all hated here.
They...
Then why are they still here?
Huh?
Why did they let me capture them?
Let's say 10% avoid capture.
They could break out at any time they want.
That's on them.
That's all I'm saying.
They did not have this work here.
They could just...
Why don't you just leave?
Okay.
Let's see.
all right let's see uh we need to upgrade our oh yeah we
have we can afford the this now all right nice let's make
this wait who said that kevin ashwell okay thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you all right kevin don't worry
kevin i see you i see you kevin
Give me a sec, Kevin.
I need to start producing something first.
Don't worry, Kevin.
People will remember you.
I don't need that.
I'm patient.
I'm...
I'm patient
We can wait here as long as we want Eiffen, thank you for
the super chat Thank you, thank you Tokyo is such a kind
boss My house burned down Tokyo is right outside Offering me
a bed and a job Thank you for the super chat you see look at
all these testimonials about how great of a boss i am chat
let's see let me grab something real quick well this is
burning i need to grab something real quick guys i need yeah
look at all of those it's okay guys i can wait
i'm patient here we're gonna sleep and eat good question
zion thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i feel
very called out right now thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you uh mercy thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you though he was kind and took me after I lost my
family to that axe-wheeling Oregon office day.
Oh, my God, who could it be?
Who would do such a thing?
That's so fucked up.
Who would just harvest organs just willy-nilly like that?
Oh, my.
I would never.
I'm a con boss.
I took them in when they had nobody to support them.
Road, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Coming home after a long day of work Are you laughing?
It's all worth it.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Affiliant, thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
And Sean, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
All right, guys.
Okay.
See, they're happy.
They're a happy worker.
All right.
Oh, where's my work desk?
Okay.
Let's see.
Wait.
No.
Okay.
Wait.
all right all
right kevin make it
that's right kevin make that cleaver
hey kevin why don't you tell me more about your ideas to
unionize kevin i would love to hear more about it while
you're making that cleaver.
Why don't you?
Why didn't you tell me more?
I'd love to hear about it.
Like, what are your ideas?
What started these ideas in your head?
Come on, Kevin.
You were so into this idea before.
Kevin.
Why don't you tell me more?
I'm so curious.
I'm really, really curious.
I feel like, you know what?
You were right.
Maybe we should unionize, then.
Maybe we should.
You were right.
I just, I need to know some of these brilliant ideas you
had.
Oh, you're happy?
Oh, you did a good job, Kevin.
You did such a good job.
Oh my god.
You did such a good job, man.
You're happy, right?
You're such a happy worker.
You're such a happy worker, man.
I beg of you.
Why, guys?
Why are you scared?
I don't understand.
are you guys all so scared for kevin chat he's he's doing
his best all right kevin wow you had let me look at your
resume real quick let me look at your report your report c
uh let me let me look at your report real quick
Kevin.
Get over here.
You know, let's let me take you to a business trip, Kevin.
No, no, actually.
Let's get all the folks here.
Let's get all your friends here, too, guys.
Wait, let's get
let's get let's get all your friends here.
All your friends are here.
Aren't you happy?
They all want to see you.
They all want to see you!
That's right!
Alright.
Nice.
And I think Kevin, who?
We never had a Kevin.
I don't know what you guys are talking about.
We never had a Kevin in this company.
Oh.
why do you know is that you all love working here right
dragons you all love it here right
nobody knew a kevin there's no records of a kevin that
worked in jokie bird production incorporated uh tacos thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you blood for the
blood god yeah see cleaver this is a pickaxe guys what are
you guys talking about this is a this is just a pickaxe we
don't have a cleaver here all right anyway i feel like what
do we need what do we need um i feel like we're high enough
level to see let me see what technology can i have i can
have a mill a wheat plantation.
Ooh, a monitoring stage.
I love those.
That's going to be good for us in the future.
Sphere workshop.
Ooh, a viewing cage.
Yep.
All right.
Kaz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Loving these frog legs.
They're serving at the cafeteria today.
Good stuff, boss.
Really?
Ah, thanks.
I made it myself.
I decided to be nice today and make food for all the
dragons.
Mr. Broken Bond.
Thank you.
Remember his words?
Mr. Broken Bonds?
Alright, give me a sec here.
What a cute little chicken.
Let me adopt you real fast.
Let me adopt you.
Who said that?
Alright.
I'm gonna take you here.
Let's see.
Whoops.
Yeah.
You know what they say over here?
You know, oh, you want to get out of the water?
No, no, no.
You don't get out of the water, Mr. Broken Bonds.
You stay in the water.
Oh.
Are you drowning, sir?
What were your final words again?
Yeah.
What do you say?
Oh, Mr. Broken Bonds.
Oh, wait, why are you running away?
Why are you running away?
I don't understand.
Hmm?
Oh, don't worry.
You were a good worker, Mr. Broken Bonds.
A very, very good worker.
that's right look at the waterfall look at the waterfall all
right there's never a mr broken bonds
there there was no i don't know there's there's never been a
mr broken bonds record
actual junior another orphan oh my gosh i love orphans
they're they're the best kind of workers in my company um
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you your dad
well he never worked here but if you need a home and you
need food uh feel free to join toky bird production
incorporated um silence that's all we will remember thank
you thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you
Let's see I need to upgrade my base Yeah Let's see Alright
we're gonna like I'm gonna I'm not ending stream Until I
fucking Fly To the oil rigs Hero just sent me the map To the
oil rigs I know where it is I need to like Figure out I need
to catch a flyer I'm gonna fly That's all I care about We're
not ending until we fly Oh yeah Do you guys need food Are
you guys starving uh to the oil rig dude the dragon are the
dragons hungry well there's so many cats there's so many
cats all right let's see what do i need to upgrade i need oh
i need beds shit okay you're right i feel generous today
let's see all right i feel generous today guys don't don't
pretend I didn't do nothing for you guys don't think I did
nothing I am a generous boss all right let's see Sheila
thank you the super chat thank you thank you I just got here
and win this a murder no no they're all on they're on
business trips I just sent them They got promoted.
What are you talking about?
All those goons, all your coworkers, they got promoted and
they're going on a business trip.
We're expanding, guys.
We made enough in our quarterly reports to expand.
And I sent them all to, like, business trips, you know, to,
to, like, make deals with the other companies.
Recycle bins.
They give for the Aka, Aka, Aka, Aka, Aka, Aka.
Bounty hunter, huh?
Yeah.
Yeah, we're here to hunt.
That's our company.
We're just hunting bounties.
We're going to establish a new branch, guys.
We're expanding.
You guys should be proud of yourselves for your hard work.
We were able to expand because of all your hard work, guys.
promoted they went to the farm out in the country i don't
know what you're talking about guys all your friends
neighbors and family and we all got promoted all right let's
see i guess i can give you guys 20 berries i'm so nice wow
it's like you guys are hungry why you guys are so hungry
okay i'm gonna put monkey in here because monkey can chop oh
and then we definitely need berries so we'll chop more wood
we'll chop more wood dragons at the world you have nothing
to live in but your chains this became the miserable right
now like hungry games Le Miserale you guys all know what
happened in Le Miserale you guys know what happened you guys
want to repeat history you think there was a happy ending
for that movie slash musical it's cute that you thought
there was a happy ending did you hear the track and sing
singing the way
all right let's see we can expand oh we can upgrade okay now
we just need water um we will prevail that's that's silly
you guys are so silly all right let's see we gotta we gotta
the uh we gotta grab the water palettes too i don't know
where the water palettes are viva revolution
that's that's cute
that's cute that you think that you think.
Remember, there's only one promotion, guys.
There's only one promotion, and you have to...
You have to be able to defeat the Prime Dragoon here.
That's the only promotion you can get.
If you want to make a real difference in Doki Bird
Incorporated,
Dragoon Prime.
Where are the water, guys?
I know you guys exist somewhere.
Okay.
Does he give me stuff?
He gives me like, oh yeah, he gives me fragments.
Okay, we're gonna have to we're gonna have to use the
pickaxe now.
And with the...
Where are the water, guys?
I need them to water my fucking berries.
Where are you?
you guys exist.
I know you're around here.
Come on.
We just need one.
Hunter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Bro, 20 bears ain't gonna feed my dead family at this point.
That's why in Doki Bird Incorporated, we only employ
orphans.
Thank you for...
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Bodacious.
Thank you.
Here at Doki Industries, we treat you like family.
Definitions of family may vary.
Thank you for the super chat.
Oh, no.
Do the frogs water?
The frogs water, right?
Did they actually?
I don't remember.
I'm going to grab this.
And then...
Yeah.
It's okay.
We're your family now.
We employ orphans so you can be Stockholm syndromed.
to staying with Doki Bird Incorporated because then we
become your family.
I guess you have nothing left.
What's that?
Is that the cat?
That's the cat.
I'm gonna double check.
I'm gonna check the frogs.
Wait, can I check the frogs in a paldeck?
Maybe I can check the frogs here.
Let's see.
Oh, they do!
Wait, then who plants the seeds?
Was it the monkey?
Did my monkey plant?
Oh!
I didn't need you guys anyway.
Okay, we're good.
We're good to go.
Liam, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Give her a lesson in French history.
Use her neck against her.
You remember what they did to the monarchy?
Good luck.
Good luck cutting this neck.
Good luck with that.
Yo, you won't be able to find one long enough.
Alright, let's see.
Okay, we gotta go back home.
Yeah, uh...
You missed.
Wait.
Hey, you're shiny.
Oh, is that a shiny dragon?
I'm done playing with.
Oh my god.
oh my god he's huge he's huge wait he's so big oh my god oh
my god our first shiny our first shiny dragoon get over here
get over here i need you i need you what the fuck since when
can they breathe fire what since when do they breathe fire
holy shit they breathe fire all right nice okay let's um
let's head over here real fast All right, I captured a lucky
pal.
All right.
Hmm.
Okay.
Are you?
Okay, give me a sec.
Uh...
All right.
Give me a sec real quick.
Oh, everybody's gone.
Ooh, that's good.
Everybody's gone.
Look into...
Look at that beautiful waterfall, Dragoon.
Isn't that waterfall beautiful?
Oh my god.
It's so beautiful, Dragoon.
All those memories we had together.
Um...
We were there.
My very first pal that I caught.
It was such a good time.
had together.
It was such a quiescent dragon.
We had such, now turn around.
Turn around and look at that waterfall.
Isn't it beautiful?
Hello.
My one and only dragon that has always been there for me.
Ha ha ha ha.
you've always been there since the very beginning the
original dragon
what do you mean he's always been there he grew so much oh
my god he grew so much since we started in the beginning
Daisy, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
We're getting company-wide promotion today, boys.
Guys, I told you guys, I told all of you guys, did I not say
that the moment, um, that like, um, did I not say that you
can thrive under yokey bird productions because look
remember him this is what he looks like now remember dragon
prime this is what he looks like now
when we first when we first recruited the original dragon he
was not he was but a tiny now look at him he's thriving he's
thriving in the company he's he got fat enough he grew
taller he's getting all the ladies and the men
oh my god i told you we can thrive i told you this company
is thriving i fucking knew it And we'll get the lamb over,
too.
Let's see.
What do we...
Okay, we...
We need...
We need to fly.
We need to get something ready to go fast.
Johnny LeCone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We're witnessing ongoing.
Next, it will be a little pictures having corrections done
to them.
Thank you for the super chat, Johnny.
Thank you.
thank you um netppers thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you that's absolutely right doki i'm happy to be here
as always we work hard but we play hard too by making work
fun oh my god that is peak dragoon worker right there thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you i'm glad you guys
understand i'm glad i'm glad you all understand
i'm glad you all understand
uh why don't i throw it out thank you super chat thank you
thank you shake my hand the new hires always get promotions
and raises before the employees who have been here for years
It's just like real life.
Wow, Toadale.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He just wasn't working hard enough, Wow, Toadale.
I don't know.
You could have, you worked a little harder.
Maybe you too can get that promotion.
All right.
Let's grab that ice organ.
We need to expand our other business, our organ harvesting
business.
Zelle, thank you, and Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, Doki, congrats on the Skinsuit Day boom.
amazing!
Today's my birthday, and I was wondering if I could get a
big happy birthday from the star of the show herself.
Thank you, guys, of course.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Zell.
Yay!
Hey, we need to grab a wolf so we can use it as a mount,
because I'm tired of running.
um eddie thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
after lots of re-education i've come to love my boss over
and lord and i'll see the air of my ways that's good to know
man but we don't call it re-education here because it's a
choice if you want to go to dokeyburg university okay it's a
choice we put you in that room you can leave at any time in
that room and you know it's not like like it's not like you
were chained to the desk so you couldn't get up and leave
you can Get up and leave at any time you want.
It's not like we were force-feeding you until you
understood.
Weird.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So I got promoted last week.
Here's some of my paychecks, so please don't promote me.
That's so cute.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, don't you love working at Dokey Bird Production
Incorporated?
Don't you love it?
working here it's not a cult it's a business it's a family
business with me and my all my all my orphans
yeah we love it here can you climb oh upgrade time upgrade
upgrade yeah Yeah.
Okay.
Yes, we said in unison.
I'm glad we understand.
I'm glad we all understand.
Oh, my God.
It's so...
Wait, I went the wrong way.
Wait, what?
Is this new the way it did that?
I went the wrong way, guys.
I want to get that fast travel.
Fuck you, I'm too lazy.
I'll get that fast travel another time.
I know, like, the wolves are, like, here, right?
Wait, I should just...
I should just go to the other spawn, honestly.
Alright, let's find the closest.
Alright, the closest is, like, all the way over there.
Come on.
Come on, dragon.
We need a...
We need a wolf.
By getting a wolf, we can...
can get a we can get flyer and by getting a flyer we can go
to the oil rig and then after getting to the oil rig we end
the stream that's that's all i want gordon thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you um this all could have been
avoided if you just gave us dental dungy thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you gordon all i'm saying is that
if i Any point, if any point you need Denta, you'll get a
promotion.
Uh, I'm not baking, because that was a great idea.
Thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you, thank you.
The bodies of my brother's litter, the streets, jagoons
don't stand for this tyranny.
Don't enter the...
Rise against the bourgeoisie.
Thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you, thank you.
let's see guys who else has some who else also have some
amazing ideas that they would like to share with the class
with the company with the board with the board of director
one director it's a shame that like it's weird that we only
have one director at the board of directors I sure or don't
I don't I have no ideas oh really are you sure not even one
single idea that you want to entertain with the class with
the company not are you sure I'm always open for ideas
dragons if you want to improve the company all your
brilliant and wonderful ideas that could possibly
uh let's see guys all i want is just i just want to get the
oil i just want to get the oil guys i want to be america for
a day all right let's see there was like wasn't there like a
fucking family down there uh a family of of woes that i was
could kidnap uh let's see uh wrap Thank you for the super
chat.
Thank you, thank you.
They were over here, right?
I remember seeing a family of wolves around, like, a bunch
of eggs.
Just play it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Where did it go?
The wolves disappeared.
There was a family of wolves down.
What the fuck?
They're gone.
You guys saw it.
We all saw it.
Where did it go?
I knew that was a...
fucking weird spawn i told you guys i was like that's a
fucking weird spawn i was like i'd never seen that before
that the fucking does the the woes spotting around a bunch
of eggs just play think of the super chat thing thank you
don't believe the propaganda it's a business we are a family
our boss is perfect um and we are happy just look at dragoon
prime they grew three times their instantly from pure love
because they enjoy they joined the family business um they
were the first orphan to join the family business and now
look at him look at him
look at how big and strong he is now uh kevin thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you doki my father died at
your hand for the Wait, who?
I don't know.
Father, he never worked here.
I only recruit orphans.
I don't know.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Let's see.
Does anyone know where the wolves are?
I literally just need one wolf.
I remember seeing them here.
Where the fuck?
are the wolves how do they know how did they know who
snitched who snitched in the company and told them I was
looking for the wolves who gave the wolves intel before I
could arrive let's see they might think they can run away
from those Boogie Bird Incorporated.
But you can never truly run away from a company that's
expanding.
Company is always expanding.
Lieutenant, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, meow.
And you think of the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
They think they think they are safe.
But there's always one wolf.
There's always one pal that struggles behind the others all
I need is one wolf oh hey an egg nice are you hungry drag
room prime are you hungry here you go don't you love eggs
they're so delicious
on these elephants they know i hate them go dragon prime go
all right there's always one straggler
there is always one straggler they think that wolf thinks
he's the wolves think they're being smart right now they
think they think they're being so cheeky but i know i know
there's always one i'm not afraid all you need is one wolf
all right let's look at the pal deck wolves dire wolves
habitat how how is this like prime
This is literally prime wolf territory Fuck
This is prime wolf territory Where did all these fucking
wolves go?
They know, I don't need
it They're actually hiding That's actually crazy Oh my god
Why are they afraid of me?
It's my next bounty.
How can they be so scared?
Does the company provide a dental?
That's a good question.
Why don't you join the company and find out?
Uh, alright.
I can't believe it.
This is literally...
This is where they live.
This is literally where they live.
I only have one target here.
Just one.
We saw so many wolves earlier.
That's the worst part.
We saw like a million of them.
Let's see.
Cypher, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
A good worker is alive work.
You're free to live and work.
A bad worker sees a waterfall.
Don't be a bad worker.
Payday for good workers has been postponed.
Payday for bad workers is canceled.
Thank you for the super chat, Cypher.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't know why they're avoiding me.
I just want one or...
Oh, there you are.
I see you.
All it takes is one war.
the the last remaining wolf out there oh i see you
come on
found an orphan guys i did it i found a fucking orphan
We did it, guys.
Orphan Kai.
Where's his family?
He literally was the last remaining wolf out there.
Gary, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, guys.
We just need to face the truth.
This is a...
Oh, isn't it a what?
Sorry, his connection cut out before I could read the rest
of his message.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Sheena, thank you for the super chat.
made a Twitter for getting a dragon theme music.
We just hit 20k.
Whoa!
You guys gotta get your own own song.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I was gonna talk more about the orchestra shit during the
behind the scenes, guys.
don't worry.
I'll talk more about the orchestra.
I hired in the behind the scenes stream on Saturday.
Coyote, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
have one coyote to work for us in Doki Bird Incorporated.
We finally got him.
He thought...
He thought he was being so... We found it.
The straggler... I told you guys there's always one
straggler.
Despite all the other was running away and hiding, there's
always going to be one wolf that I did not get the message.
It's always one wolf that didn't get the message from all
the other wolves.
And now he works for me now.
Thank God he was an orphan too.
So I don't have to do extra work for...
So I don't have to make him an orphan.
That's the best part.
That's the best part, chat.
Isn't it great?
Alright.
Off we go.
Off we go back home, Dragon Prime.
We're going home.
We're getting a mount.
Oh, a dire wolf mount.
And then.
And then we're going to kidnap a flying guy.
And after we kidnap the flying guy, go to the oil rig off to
ventures we go dragon man remember when i first caught you
dragon and like when i first spawned here and you were the
very first pal i ever caught those were good times oh hey
there's the other wait there's another wolf there was no
other wolf
Don't worry.
Dragoon's Prime's coming.
There was never another wolf.
We only found one wolf, guys.
We only found one.
There we go.
I made sure to get the job done.
Finish the job myself.
Mirchel, thank you for the five.
Give the show.
Yes, thank you.
Thank you.
Let's see.
I mean, if you get caught first, then you are the lucky one.
Isn't it?
Does that mean you were lucky if you get caught first?
Alright.
Let's head home.
There's only one teleporter here, apparently.
Hmm.
Alright.
Let's go.
Let's head over.
Let's head home.
And then after we head home.
We...
We gotta find the...
What were they called?
They're like those mini dragons.
I think I can... I think I have enough materials too for
them.
There can only be one.
What other woes?
I see no other woes.
Exactly.
There's never been other woes.
What are you guys talking about?
Uh, this way.
Oh my gosh.
And then by the time I get home, I can a saddle for the wolf
and then when I get the saddle I don't have to run like a
fucking peasant then I can be carried like the CEO I am of
Doki Bird Productions
incorporated a bounty hunter is like a hitman except you're
given a choice to leave them alive.
Like, sometimes, but 99% of my choices is not leaving them
alive.
But there's the 1% chance.
There's the 1% chance that you get to live.
So that's why I'm not a hitman.
Okay, it should be, like, around here.
What the fuck is it?
It's, like, here somewhere.
Okay.
What the fuck?
I don't want you to climb!
Okay, this way.
I don't like the odds.
It's like gotcha.
You guys are willing to gotcha wifus with a 0.1% chance of
hitting your gotcha.
But, oh, apparently when it's life or death, you...
That's where you draw the line.
Wait, I can ride this bird.
Wait, fuck that.
I mean...
Wait, I can't...
Fuck!
I don't have a bow and arrow.
No!
This bird!
Oh.
I didn't make a bow and arrow!
God damn it.
I forgot to get a bow.
I forgot to craft a bow and arrow.
I knew I forgot to craft something.
Wait, do I actually not?
No!
I could have just got that and be happy!
Just throw up...
Oh, you're right.
Just throw a bird.
I just saw...
Throw a ball at it.
You're right.
I'm so stupid.
Yeah, but I have like a regular pal.
Wait, where did it go?
No, and then it despawned?
What?
Did it despawn?
That fast?
I literally looked away for one second.
I actually looked away for one second and then, wait,
meteorite descent?
Wait what?
Where?
On me?
Oh.
What the fuck is that the other area?
Okay, we gotta go there.
Wait, that's actually pretty cool.
We gotta go there.
Alright.
Alright, it was like over there.
Alright, chicken.
We're gonna go.
Okay, we can't die.
We're like level 15.
We have like... Wait, I want to see what the meteorite is.
Wait, what?
There's a meteorite.
I want to see.
I'm interested now.
Oh my god, fly.
It's swim.
Fly away now.
Fly away.
Look, we have the stamina now.
What the fuck?
Send it, get clear.
Oh my god, we can knock over there.
Oh my god.
This area is dangerous.
What's going on over there?
What the fuck?
What the fuck is going...
What is that?
Oh my god.
Let's go to the meteorite.
Hey, there's a blue one.
Wait, where did the meteorite land?
I don't even know.
I don't even know where the meteorite land is, chat.
Like, I don't even...
Where the fuck did the meteorite land?
That was it?
That was the meteor?
Oh
He's the meteor Oh my god, it is Wait, we have a chance The
syndicate is stuck in the wall and she can't kill it
The thing he sees me Oh, whoa, whoa
Noink, noink, noink
Oh, my purple ball Oh oh yeah one point two oh seven okay
okay my 34 no okay i have one more oh god oh god oh god okay
this is it No!
Zero percent!
Oh, my Megasphere.
My Megasphere.
No!
Yeah, three chances.
Oh, no.
I need to use the bathroom, guys.
We're going to look out into the water with...
I'll be right back.
I need to use the bathroom.
Us and Dragon Prime can look at each other.
Wait, where are you going?
You are not fighting.
You are not fighting her.
are not fighting her we're just gonna be coming over no
we're just gonna look out into the ocean guys i'll be back
i'll be back all
right dad get off all right all right guys what what are you
guys talking about here tell me your leader who's your
leader no no no i just i just want to talk I just I just
want to talk and negotiate who's the leader come on who's
the who's the leader guys I just want to talk that's it
just a simple question Liam thank you for the thank you
thank you dragons her soul has left their body now Oh, Liam!
You're the leader.
Why don't you...
Liam, why don't you come with me to the boardroom?
And we can have a little talk.
Liam, thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you.
Bring your credit card, too.
Alright, let's see.
Let's go over there.
Let's go over here.
And we need...
We literally just need...
the craft a mount and when we craft the mount we can get it
we can ride the wolf and when we ride the wolf we can catch
a flyer and when we catch the flyer when we catch the flyer
we can finally we can finally go to the oil rig that's all i
want i just want to go to the oil rig
do though so we can like get them to come down so let's see
i have not fucking tech i did not do technology for the bow
i like how i don't even have armor i i know what i want i
don't even have armor okay well grab an old old bow i don't
think i need honestly i don't need like a better bow
have a we have a complaint box right now so like if you want
to complain about anything feel free uh feel free to put
that super
um it's in the super chat box um and we are actually
starting a new policy it's called a cinches don't get
stitches uh so if you see any fellow dragoons doing
something that you believe is against company policy you can
drop your uh you can drop your note at the snitches uh don't
get stitches boxes uh i'll name anybody you want anonymously
so do not worry let's see i need it oh yeah i need make like
that um um the mounting okay i need leather okay i can
afford it yay uh don't trust her lies let's see and it's
production so high quality workbench is it high quality
workbench i feel like Ooh.
What workbench was it?
See, I feel like it wasn't high quality workbench, right?
It was like something else.
Tavern, wooden, ranch.
Oh, Palgear.
There we go.
I have everything for it.
Okay.
Where is the Palgear?
Palgear.
All right.
Doki, please help the Italian local join up.
The prices of hero subs with a real mozzarella to like $16.
I'm addicted to expensive status sandwiches.
What did you do?
Okay, Anton did not understand what the complete box was
for.
I am not in charge of the cafeteria of the cafeteria
sandwiches.
That is a different branch.
All right.
Thank you, the super chap.
Thank you.
the this thing all right get over here uh let's see i saw
the ceo stealing pens out of the supply closet separate
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you look i the
the pens come from my paycheck okay technically i'm sharing
my pens for all of you so you're welcome
Alright, uh...
I can't remember how to give this guy...
Okay, it's automatically, yeah.
Alright, um...
Then I have to...
Uh...
Okay, there you go.
Alright.
Do I need more balls?
No, that should be enough.
That should be enough balls.
Alright, there we go.
Boss HR checking in.
jamming the shredder on your complaint box by putting Kevin
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you Ali thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you oh just put that
just put that in the um just put that in the complaint put
that complaint in the complaint box again don't worry
somebody will get to your complaint don't worry um maybe if
I sandblast from up here wait I can okay that's funny I
didn't know that wait I can okay Whoa, he dodged it!
No!
Holy shit!
Okay, I caught him, I caught him.
Oh my god, I gotta run now.
I gotta run!
Get over here!
I need him!
Get you on the mound!
Go run!
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
He's not aggroed anymore.
Alright.
Let's see.
well thank you for the super chat thank you thank you boss
it here they keep subscribing to porn and affecting the
computers with virus make it you are part of the it team by
they do you mean you all right let's see okay i got a bird
it's time it's time wait i didn't research it sorry it's not
time yet
okay give me a sec let me let me grab this okay i need
leather cloth and ink i need 15 ingots oh my god how do i
get cloth again okay i need to kill a lot of things give me
a sec all right we need fire and all right i can't find a
cafeteria sandwiches where are they Oh my god, there's so
many things I should have been doing Okay Campfire Do I not
have campfires?
Did I not upgrade?
Okay Where the fuck is the campfire?
Alright, campfire Okay Guys, we got a We're a bit of a mess
right now Boom Build this Alright And then We can upgrade
all right and then fire give me my shit all right we gotta
kill what brings leather again guys does anyone remember
what brings letter because i don't
you need uh no we don't need a secretary dragoon don't worry
the complaints are definitely going towards me guys do not
worry don't worry i'm reading all the complaints are going
straight to the ceo and i am reading every single one of
them do not worry do not i know it's weird when you're
putting your complaints down that you hear like the sound of
the shredder going but that's just like um that's just
ambient noises uh from the guys you're not hearing any
shredding going along i'm hearing every single one of your
complaints i am here for you guys okay that should be enough
i think why are you angry i should be angry with all the
hard work i'm doing um i definitely need a repair wrench
though it's just white noise uh all right let's see Okay,
repair.
Repair.
Wait, what do I need to do?
Oh, yeah, I need more ore.
And then I need leather.
I need leather and cloth.
So that means I need to kill more of the sheep.
Sorry, I need to promote some of the sheep.
And where do I get leather again?
I don't remember.
I don't remember where to get leather.
Dental only available to Dragoon Prime.
They don't even have...
Maybe if you get promoted to Dragoon Prime, you would
understand.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Or the foxes?
They were the foxes.
All right.
Thanks for letting me know.
There should be foxes down here.
Hello?
Wait, where did the fox go?
They were supposed to be here.
Why is it that every time... Oh, hey, there's free leather.
Okay, that's good.
Every time I need leather.
They just disappear.
Every time.
I just don't understand.
okay i need leather and i need to kill the sheep we saw a
lot of the sheep earlier too there's only where the fuck are
they it should be around here oh i know you have wolf i know
wait what the fuck all right no you bring oh wait no there
we go cloth i know i needed the wool all right get over here
what ping what is this ping because you're fluffy that's why
i knew where the fuck are they it's almost night time they
should be showing up from like like from this alone oh well
i'll just kill you guys double kill double kill all right
nice and then going to grab the fast travel here.
And did I grab the will yet?
No.
Willow time.
That's so odd that they're not here.
Let's see.
That's so odd.
Where the fuck are they?
Where are the foxes?
Am I going to have to travel all the way here to find the
foxes again?
Oh my god.
Our first
Remember where you came from.
Oh, there you are.
Wait, I actually had to.
Remember your origin.
That's actually crazy that they're here.
You remember this place, guys?
Boss, as an employee, do I get...
a pension plan and a 401k yes you actually do cyber thank
you for these super chat thank you thank you that's a really
good question the moment you hit pen the moment you retire
and leave the company we uh you just have to go to the
special room to your left there's an exit on the on the
other side i know some of you guys are wondering like hey
how come every time a dragoon goes into that special room
they don't come out it's because we actually have an exit
door um We have two doors in that room And the exit door is
actually on the other side of the room And that's why you
don't see them come out
Yes, every time you hit retirement age And ready to retire
with your pension plan and your 401k Remember to visit the
special room to receive your pension plan Okay, do I have
enough now?
Actually, I don't know.
I'm going to double check
I'm going to double check it's sleep time it's sleep time do
i have enough let me double check though we need oh my god
we need so much more okay we need we need 20 leather i have
to kill so many i mean i have to re-edge
i have to promote so many foxes i can't believe i have to
promote so many
my god i have to promote so many foxes that's crazy okay
you're promoted and you're promoted um and congratulations
you get a promotion too you just got hired and you got
promoted so lucky and you get promoted let's see what what
god it's so great to work for dokeybird no not promotion oh
my god congratulations you are what we're looking for you
have the face and the leather and you too promo ships for
everybody oh why don't you want to get promoted i don't
understand um that's a deadpool thank you for the super chat
thank you oh my god is that gold no that's a regular egg god
damn it i thought i was a golden egg a golden egg That's a
deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Janitor here.
The garbage chute in the time room keeps getting clogged
with these really heavy trash bags.
I could really use some help cleaning it out.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thanks for letting me know.
Sorry we only have one janitor.
We couldn't really afford to hire another one.
An egg!
I can raise this orphan myself.
nice all right let's see I thought you guys wanted
promotions what happened when you guys want to get promoted
you guys were like I want a promotion too why do these
dragons get promoted and I don't all right let's grab let's
get these guys out of the way whoa come on whoa Oh, come on.
Oh, why are you running?
And why are you running?
Why are you running?
Woo!
Okay, nice.
Do I have enough?
Let's see.
Cloth, 13.
Was it, how many leather do we need in?
Was it 15 or 20?
Native reinforcements.
You need 20?
Okay.
Oh my god.
We're almost there.
The things we do to see the oil rig.
I just wanted to see the oil rig.
That's all I...
I just wanted my cheese.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Um.
the elk does elk give you letter
all right come over here
okay okay you know what you can fight him yourself i don't
want to control them anymore you can fight it yourself
darwolf you got this wait i actually want to catch him all
right then you kill this other guy nice oh okay i guess i
don't need dialk i guess no they don't even give leather
lied they don't even give leather oh hey oh my god everybody
uses you as employees because you do it because you don't
even need a pay you are the optimal employee don't shoot me
don't shoot me don't shoot me nice okay we got optimum
employee here they don't even said elk.
Because you're going to get a promotion.
Whoever said elk, congratulations.
You're getting a promotion very soon.
See.
No, please.
For that.
For that wonderful idea that you had.
Um.
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you guys uh hey
that looked just like my office all right let's we need to
find a uh what is in me all right we need to find a merchant
so i'm trying to remember the town for it because i know
like we can find the town for that too let's just kill these
guys for easy letter i'm not easy letter easy wool that we
can make into the saddle oh my god the things we do for
leather oh we can loot this we can loot while we're on the
mount let's go all right yeah i'm trying to i'm trying to
find do they give leather what do they give oh they do oh my
god you're cute and useful all right nice all right okay we
have 15 oh my god we're almost there we're almost there all
right it's this way and then
yeah where are you i'm gonna get off this to mine to mine
this for a little bit Because I think we need a little bit
of ore or two.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure we're, like, missing a little bit of ore.
I think, like, five more?
Maybe?
Right?
I don't know.
Just in case.
I don't know where to buy, Leslie.
I don't remember the town.
It's been too long.
I don't remember where the town is.
Okay.
I guess we enhanced it for catching.
Oh, hey, it's him!
Wait, what?
Oh, shit.
You're hungry?
Alright, don't worry.
Wait, he's new.
Hello?
Oh, he's a dog coin!
This is what I mean!
He's a dog coin!
He's the NFT!
Uh...
Light fruit that slightly increases.
All purpose pallets extract.
Uh...
A mysterious extract that can be injected into the pallet.
The multi-climate and esoteric that raises heat and cold.
Ring of fright?
Whoa!
That's a lot.
Shape like a...
I don't have enough dog coin.
Oh yeah, I want this.
Okay.
Wait, I want to have a hat.
That's so cute.
I need 50 dog coin.
How do I get 50 dog coin?
I mean, this is not fair.
That's not fair.
I don't want to get fucking more dog coin.
Guys, why did we not invest in that?
Okay, I shouldn't joke.
I shouldn't.
I don't know.
joke about that um oh my god we need more leather okay let's
see west of here is it this way who embezzled all their dog
coins all right let's see wait is that the town that's a
town because that's smoke coming from it it has to be this
town there's no fall damage i remembered yeah oh thank god i
i that was so risky i actually don't remember that to to be
fair i actually don't remember all right i know you have
letter i know you have letter and i'm desperate uh let's see
oh there's more woes there's more woes don't need the egg we
have enough orphans um all right that's good we need the
wolves okay whoop whoop nice give over here get over here
nice all right oh that's two letter he was extra thick guys
get over here wait actually oh that's a lot of thugs that's
a lot you know what You guys get over here.
I want you.
I want you and my team.
Get over here.
Hey!
Don't worry.
You're gonna love living in my...
You're gonna love working for my company.
You're an orphan now.
You have no family.
The syndicate was your family?
No.
This is your family now.
us today in dokeybird incorporated um 19 god i need one more
leather i actually just need one all right let's see i just
need one more all right where are you where are you i need
leather where did we see the smoke again right here we need
to kill anything just anything All this for the oil ring.
The woes.
I knew they won't fail me.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Nice.
All right.
Is that it?
That's all I need.
All right.
Goodbye.
You guys can have your pal world.
Pal world war.
I don't care.
I got what I needed.
I got everything I need.
Alright.
Let's see.
Wait, how do I...
Where's the...
Oh, it's here.
Okay, I need to get off this so I can climb.
Climb, Doki.
Okay.
And then where?
And then where is it?
Where the fuck is it?
I don't remember where the checkpoint is.
Over there?
Oh, it's over there!
Okay.
Alright.
This is so convenient.
It's actually so convenient.
We got it!
We got it, Dragon!
We can finally afford!
We can finally make the saddle!
It only took 20 years!
But we made it!
It only took 20 years.
Where the fuck is the?
Okay, there you go.
How many more do we need?
Okay.
Ooh, items.
Wait, we don't have enough ingots.
Are you fucking kidding me?
We don't...
No.
No!
I don't have enough ingots.
Oh my god, we were almost there.
We were almost there.
I thought I had enough.
I thought I had enough ingots.
Okay, I have five.
I have five or is that enough?
That should be enough.
Oh no, he's here.
No, not the mammoth swine.
Not the mammoth rest.
Sorry, that was the Pokemon version.
It should be it.
We should have enough now, right?
We back in the mines we go.
This should be enough.
This has to be enough.
There's no way.
Where's the fire?
Okay.
Let's see.
We're in cancer.
And then...
Nine.
There we go.
Where are you?
Where the fuck is the fire guy?
Get in here.
Alright.
Let's see.
And then I need a craft cloth.
Okay.
now craft it I'm fast all right all right here we go don't
worry this should be enough I think we we finally we finally
got this is it cloth no it'll be so funny if it wasn't cloth
oh no oh no no
I literally just needed...
Bro.
I needed two ingots.
I literally just needed two ingots.
Fox Park.
Please.
Leave.
Go.
Burn.
I literally need two ingots.
That's all.
I just need two ingots.
That's all I need.
Just burn.
Alright.
That's fine.
We don't care.
It's fine.
We're still around.
We're still okay.
Oh my god.
Alright.
One.
Oh my god.
That shit's almost broken.
Is it just that that took a beating?
Oh no.
Okay.
No, it's like that and the berry.
It's just these two that took a beating.
Alright, come on.
Two!
Alright.
There we go.
Oh my god, we finally did it.
We made it.
We fucking made it.
We fucking made a goddamn sadder.
Oh my god, okay, where are my workers?
Alright.
There we go.
Alright, get over here.
Work!
Wait, I can't...
I can literally...
Enhance...
Alright, there we go.
Work!
Oh!
It only took three hours.
It only took three hours to get there.
But we made it.
We made it.
Alright.
This is it.
Oh my god.
Wait, actually.
Actually.
Let's put the others.
Oh.
What did I need?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
There was something I need to build.
There we go.
Almost forgot.
The most important thing.
the oh my my most in my most important thing in this world
goon goon
in you goon
oh yeah you're right no you guys are more creative
you're right how could I forget.
Also known as Sound Guy.
There we go.
There you go.
Look at him work.
How's the sound?
Sound Guy.
This is where I keep my mods.
Yes.
I keep my mods right here.
That's right.
This is where the sound guy lies.
Alright, I feel like I need a knight goon.
And then a wolf goon.
There you go.
Alright, it's time.
Oh my god, it's finally time.
It's finally time.
Get over here.
Finally!
Okay, guys, I need it.
How do I get there?
How do I... Guys, let me look at the map.
Guys, let me...
Let me look at...
Let me... Give me a sec.
I need a look at the map.
Hiro sent me the map.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
It's all the way over there.
Alright.
Don't worry.
We're gonna head over.
It's over there.
Do you see it?
It's over there!
it's right over there do you see it wait actually I don't
know if it is over there is that it is that it okay give me
this is that it okay I think it's over here
maybe it's here I'll figure this out guys it's somewhere
okay it's like some is that it where is it he don't
literally send me a map what the fuck is that no it's like
here it's like we're not lost we're gonna find the oil this
is the most important place we have to go like somewhere
here is that it what is the circle that i'm this general
area I was told it was this general area okay so no there's
no oil rigs here the fuck is the oil rig it's not the oil
rig that's an island that's the fucking island what the fuck
is this oil rig oh Wait, I think it's like here.
Oh, don't worry.
Oh, she can't...
I can't read the map.
No, it's not.
It's like, for some reason, the oil rig is on the opposite
side of everything.
It's like the Sakura Jima is like over there, but the oil
rig is over here.
Okay, Marsh Islands.
Okay, we're close.
We're close because I remembered.
I remembered the instructions.
It was next to Marsh Islands.
I remember.
I know my instructions.
I think.
Okay.
It's like.
In this general area.
Is that it?
Guys, do you see that?
That has to be the oil rig.
Do you see that?
That pool in the distance?
Wait, I think it is.
Why is there a pool there?
Why?
Guys, we need our oil.
We need our oil.
Oh my.
Guys, I think this is it.
Guys.
Guys, I think it is it.
This is the oil break.
Guys, we're at the oil break.
Guys.
Guys, it's July 4th, guys.
Oh my god.
It's finally July 4th!
The oil break is real!
Guys, you guys have to think I'm dead.
No, no!
No!
My item!
What the fuck was that?
Oh my god!
They have deference?
What the fuck?
Since when did they have deference?
I can't get on the wall!
They have anti-air?
Oh no, since when?
When did oil breaks?
I'm dead.
Dead guys.
No, we're so close.
We're so close.
Please.
We're just there.
No.
Oh my god.
Well, that was what a fun adventure we had to get there.
Guys.
Well, that was so fun, everybody.
Right hand.
I had such a fun time, guys.
This is what the fuck did oil rings have entire?
I was not worn by...
No.
Nobody warned me!
Three hours for a Luizu show.
I just wanted to go to the oil rig!
Asasaka and Jima!
I just wanted to see the oil rig!
I can't believe there was death rays!
That was crazy!
Oh my god!
Why was there death rays?
Why?
I need to take off my jacket after that oh my god i can't
believe oh my god i can't believe there was oil there was a
death ray to protect the oil of course oh i can't believe it
i just i they do they they heard They were like the
American, the Canadian cowboy trying to roleplay as the
American is coming.
Oh my god, I just, I wasn't gonna take the oil.
I swear, I wasn't gonna, I wasn't gonna go for an American
and take the oil.
I just wanna see the oil.
I swear, just, I just wanted to see the oil.
Is that too much to ask for?
is that is that really too much i had a fun time though um i
had a i hope you guys had a really fun time watching too it
was a lot we had a lot going on today uh we streamed for
like almost three we're like streamed like three and a half
hours i was like i didn't expect to stream that long today
but i was having a lot of fun with you guys um guys i'm
gonna i'm tired uh but we have uh we just have so much stuff
to look forward to uh in the coming week um you guys don't
follow me on twitter um i am taking a chill uh i'm gonna
chill for the next two weeks uh because uh uh because um i'm
i've been working working full speed gas gas gas for half
like you five to six five to six months now it's time to
release the gas and slow down it's time to press on the
brakes a little and slow down a little it's yellow light
time um so that's why uh we are uh we're gonna relax a
little bit i want to cool down after an intense debut debut
and it was it's it's been a fun time today dragons i hope
you guys new skin suit um thank you all for the super chats
and uh and the ships and everything guys i'm letting you
guys to know we're slowly the changing of graphics because i
know i'm still using my old icons and my old headers and
everything um i'm very very very slowly changing my graphics
for stuff and also i'm tired i know i haven't posted the
wallpapers or the 3d models or the changing icons and
everything to match my new skin suit I'm just tired It's
gonna slowly change One by one And then it's gonna get there
Okay We're just slowly Slowly getting there Anyway as always
everybody Stay hydrated Posture check Get up and move around
to get that blood flowing And if you stay up for me Head to
bed because you deserve it I'll see you guys next time
everybody Bye guys
also buy my merch buy my merch it's gonna be a diorama i
know it doesn't say that but we decided last minute to make
it into a diorama acrylic stand for the so the background
will be that that uh yippe kai yay cliff background on the
acrylic stand buy my merch bye
sorry dokey merch.com